I want to pull up this story from CNN 11
US citizens dead in Israel conflict
Biden says and then we have this from
ABC Biden says it is likely Americans
are among Hamas hostages with 11 killed
I don't see how Biden can recover from
this electorally he's already down and
now you have it it it doesn't matter
what you think it's true in fact doesn't
even matter what is true it matters what
people end up believing is true
certainly I do believe the truth matters
and we try our best to get to it but the
political ads are all going to say one
simple line under Donald Trump historic
peace agreements with Israel under Joe
Biden 11 Americans dead in escalating
conflict Afghanistan withdrawal it's
just he's going to these these his I I
don't see how he he pulls out of this
yeah when it comes to military I think
you realize that nothing else really
matters when when your survival is on
the line I haven't heard the word Trans
in like 3 days I don't I haven't seen
anything about cult cult War crap on
Twitter maybe one or two things it's all
been about the death and destruction and
potential loss of life that's all that
really matters when it comes down to
well it is indigenous people's day and
that is a big thing and I didn't even
know that until like 4:00 and I was like
are we doing a show tonight Columbus all
over Twitter oh well I I I see Israel
Palestine Gaza in my Twitter feed and
I'm glad um we need a strong military
commander that's what we need right now
I think I I so sorry Ian you were saying
you're not you used to be anti-
intervention you're not anymore would
you support us inter in Israel uh yes in
fact yes immediate intervention and For
Better or Worse to to help bring water
to the people of Gaza for starters well
that's in Palestine I guess but like so
in the region you're saying yes to
intervention I would I would like to
facilitate some sort of peace deal I'm
not I'm not advocating for blowing
people up at this and you and millions
of people for Generations would like to
broke her a peace deal good luck yeah
but uh yeah absolutely I think we need
to be it's we're the strongest military
force on Earth we need to be what do you
think you think like us boots on the
ground troops no no Israel's capable
taking you're not talking about in
intervention you're talking about you
like capable of taking care of then
military aid what do you want us to do
we're on TV man I can't really I can't
really say that stuff on TV the Biden
Administration already announced they're
giving weapons to Israel yeah for this
right now so that's already
happened I I support it I absolutely
support it man whether or not whether or
not they let this thing happen those
dudes murdered raped like they they were
they killed a from what I'm reading
about this music festival did they rape
they killed people and then they raped
women right next to their friends dead
corpses that's true this is what I've
been reading I don't this is all I mean
that could be War propaganda bro it
could be it could be maybe the whole
thing's War I don't know a lot of it is
and so watch out cu when Ukraine the
Ukraine war started all that look let's
be honest Israel is so much better at
propaganda than than but I think two
things that a man needs and will kill
for is eating and having sex and if
these men are military Ag and there are
no women in their society oh you better
believe they want to have sex yeah but
they're not it's not like these guys
were like oh I'm so angry I want to it's
more like these evil oppressors will
know when we control them and they want
to sub subjugate the people that they
they they view as oppressors right it's
a display of brutality yeah and then the
psychotic urges of masculinity come out
when they're in battle after after the
kill the man wants well it's it's not
that it's it's you're you're you're
you're thinking of it it's it's it's a
lot of it is spitting in the face of the
of Israel taking taking the women is an
insult to is Israel it was it was known
throughout time like when a when a
Alexander the Great's forces or like a a
a military force would invade and take a
city the commander would have to tell
the troops do not pillage do not rape
and if a shitty Commander wouldn't be
able to keep his troops under wraps and
they just go destroy and so like a good
Commander would keep his men from doing
it but it was just the the um proclivity
for a you know a worn out dude that just
got done putting his life on the line
his adrenaline burned out he's got women
all around him now and he hasn't had sex
in two years okay do you think we should
say put boots on the ground to uh to
liberate the weer Muslims in China no
why why not because uh China would
launch nuclear weapons if we tried to do
that oh okay so it's only because the
the people in Palestine can't actually
do anything else retaliation that we
should actually try and stop them well
no well no no no I I'm not saying that
we should put boots on the ground or
anything I think Israeli soldiers are
qualified and capable of handling that
situation right now if there's I heard
hezb may be making moves in the north um
if there's an actual full scale Invasion
into Israel and they call for help we
have to help I don't even want to but I
mean does that mean if you're saying we
shouldn't have boots on the ground how
do you want us to help like what just
I'm just really curious like um cuz if
neither side is willing to come the
table and negotiate peace what is all
the way nuclear war well what so we
shouldn't have boots on the ground but
you want to go to nuclear war well we're
talking about life and death of the
human race you have to put that on the
table what do you mean we're talking
means death for all of us yeah my
question is like why do you care about
Israel to the point where we you think
we should intervene and provide aid but
no other countries um maybe because it's
probably like our third strongest Ally
maybe next to Germany and if they go
down I think that China Russia North
Korea and Iran will take over the
world World War I but Israel is capable
fully capable they're an advanced
technologically advanced military they
are fully capable on their own of
defeating Hamas so I think a danger here
is that Israel this goes into a broader
war and Israel has in the back of their
mind well if we get into trouble the US
will bail us out that's dangerous we
don't want them thinking well if this
does escalate the US will bail us out
because then we're all of a sudden in a
really dangerous situation mhm do you
feel like Trump would have handled this
differently from your time in his
administration you know I don't know how
he would be handling it I think I think
that Trump would fully support Israel's
right to self-defense and fighting
against Hamas and and defeating them but
I think Trump is known for his restraint
and there was a similar incident where
um Saudi Arabia did a or there was some
kind of drone attack and they blamed
Iran it was it was in Yemen they blamed
Iran for a drone attack um that was
against Saudi Arabia's interests in
Yemen and Trump people were calling on
Trump to attack Iran and Trump didn't go
for it he said no absolutely not like
this isn't our conflict we're not
getting involved in it well he
specifically said that the amount of
people who would die in the retaliation
strike was not worth it it was it was uh
uh it was not what's the right word kzer
yeah that's right word not wor the
opportunity cost was too great yeah you
could say that too it it it wasn't um I
can't think of the opportunity go commer
is that what you thinking of well it it
was proportional proportional there you
go it wasn't proportional the the the
the Drone attack you know killing
hundreds of of you know militants is way
the harsh reality of War sometimes is
you want a non-proportional response in
order to make it all stop before it
escalates it's horrible to think this I
never Liv stick ethos that was what a
lot of Americans in World War II thought
with the nuclear weapons oh we I got
stung by a wasp let's go find the wasp
nest and annihilate it kind of thing
well I mean that's a little different
similar if you if people are getting
stung by wasps you probably want to get
rid of the Wasps n you better you you
don't just take out the few wasps that
stum but we're not we're not talking
about would Beal respons right yeah see
mean you eradicate all of them if one of
them stings you yeah but what you're
arguing is a a wasp stung you so you
brought a flamethrower and you wanted
all the other
wasps you wanted the other wasps to
watch it happen so that they would know
not to sting you over again that's what
you're saying I don't want them to
suffer I just want to make it
stop well you I don't want to like burn
them alive I just want the conflict to
stop I don't want to like make make them
die in pain but that doesn't mean that I
don't want them what the hell are we
doing there's no there's no solving this
I'm sorry it's War it's war and people
have chosen a side in the war have a
nice day this goes back a 100 plus years
or even longer you can right you can go
thousands of years and it's like
everyone's going to be like this land
belongs to this no this man belongs I'm
right no I'm right in the end bro I'm 37
years old this has been going on a lot
longer than I've been alive my response
is whoa why are they killing all the
civilians and what do I get Tim Israel
is an AP paride state these people are
Freedom Fighters and I'm like bro
they're killing civilians why are you
supporting Israel Israel is is getting
stealing our money America I'm like dude
I don't care about any of this like I'm
talking about these arguments what I'm
telling you is the war is bad civilians
shouldn't be dying you can't come to me
and be like Israel should not be uh uh
targeting should not be taking action
against uh uh the Hamas targets and the
alasan brigades and I'm like what
they're shooting at him the are like
what's the what's the argument you walk
outside and a guy's got a Ruger 1022 and
he's firing at you and he hit some of
your kids so and the only weapon and so
you pull out your you know your scar 20s
and then you're like I'm going to return
fire like whoa but yours is way bigger
than his it kind of feels like War's War
dude when the American colonists were uh
colonizing the North America and
slaughtering the native population it's
similar to that but we didn't have
internet video back then we have having
the same conversation like well you know
but what happen the natives would come
into town gorilla Force they'd Tomahawk
some dudes grab some women take them
back to the tribe and then the Americans
would go with their rifles and Slaughter
all of them well there's there's two
things there's two things with that lot
of the PLS Indians that was the Reg life
for Plains Indians that was an
understanding of Plains Indians
attacking other Indians within within
the United States understanding that's
what was going to happen to men and
Indigenous people right
exactly from this company IND indigenous
people in this country whatever you want
to call them that was the understanding
among PL PLS ofi that's how life was
that was the understanding that's what
they did to us they didn't take it and
it wasn't special for them in any way
this is different because as far as I
understand those regions in West Bank
Gaza were not really inhabited until
Israel became a state and there was
reason to be able to support populations
in those areas and they immigrated into
it that's what I understand about it I
may be wrong but that's what I
understand so I don't think it's the
same thing indigenous people versus
people that move migrated there after
there was a state established and allow
them to survive in those areas I don't
know if that's exactly the same it's not
comparable yeah no it's not comparable I
wouldn't I wouldn't say it is but you
know like the colony of Israel in like
1918 the the British mandate for
Palestine that was 1948 that was 1948
that was much later much later than that
well that's when Israel got formed but
the British mandate start was in 1918
you ever read I Am Legend um no I've
seen the movie the movie is is not
the movie does not relate to the story
at all the movie should never have been
made right and that it's awful the book
is much better and uh fully admit I did
not read it uh I've only seen the select
passages that convey the general concept
of what the book is about and the book
is about a guy who is um he's a vampire
hunter and he kills vampires because
vampires are bad and then in the end he
finally realizes that because the world
has fallen to vampire Ires and he is one
of the last
humans he is the legend from the
perspective of humans there's a legend
of vampires that in the middle of the
night come and kill you while you sleep
when the world became all vampires there
was a legend of a man who lurks during
the day and kills you in your sleep that
was his realization that they arrested
him and were to try him for the crimes
of murder and and they were terrified of
him he was a monster he was the monster
in the in um 2005 6 7 8 I was like screw
Israel they' they've colonized this is
unjust it should be dismantled I was in
that state of mind and then I started to
realize like that life is about power
and who controls the power controls the
narrative and your lifestyle so I'm not
willing to give up this American
republicanism for like some
anti-colonialism I'm just not man I just
don't know what the proposed solution is
right now when you have Israel for all
their faults and then Palestinians don't
want peace they want from the river to
the Sea these are act like they'll lie
to you the left lies to you the left
lies to you all the time we know they
lie we know far left lies they are evil
people they lie lie lie they're trying
to sterilized children they want you to
abort your kids they do a whole bunch of
things and then they go in politics they
lie there's a video where Jack bobic got
punched in the face and the cops
witnessed it and the far-left activists
say to the cops I didn't see anything
happen they just lie with a smug look on
their face you have videos of the people
in New York amongst their peers cheering
for the killing of civilians calling
them illegal colonizers we as regular
regular people are like okay we can
understand the nuances of military
conflict don't like these these stories
we're being told but will not tolerate
civilians at a music festival being just
murdered and dragged through the streets
then they'll lie and say oh but our poor
civilians will make propaganda videos
what is what what does one do right now
right now I don't know about anything
else all I know is I'm sitting here
right now looking at the conflict and
I'm like I've been to Israel there are
people going to the store and buying
Falafel they're not fighting with each
other why should they be murdered by
Hamas and alasan brigades they shouldn't
be okay well what happens when these
terrorists come in and start killing
civilians like they just did in the
worst possible way we've seen ever
should Israel just be like well you know
it is what it is we're being killed no
they shouldn't the reality is we want
peace we want a peace agreement
unfortunately I think overwhelmingly it
falls to the Palestinians and the
ideologues uh more so Hamas but yes in
many ways the Palestinians they just
want to to purge Israel completely what
do you do
that's not a solution that's not there's
no compromise if they're saying we don't
care what you want to negotiate we will
kill everyone I'm like okay well there's
no negotiating with these people MH and
and we're not going to let you just go
and kill a bunch of Jewish people in
Israel now you want to make an argument
that Israel's shouldn't be there or
whatever it's like okay fine but bro the
only thing they're offering is genocide
I there's no argument there's no there's
no compromise and Israel is there like
we can't we can't go back and take
change anything like that I mean I I
really stand by that peace deals always
means that someone is upset because they
lost right and this case you're
completely right there's there's not a
clear compromise and so as much as we'd
like to see a ceasefire as much as we
wouldn't like to see people lost we
wouldn't like to see civilians taking
hostage like we can all agree these
things are bad on the other hand it's
not like we can just be like hey guys
stop stop fighting just stop like that's
obviously not a reasonable solution it's
not logical in any way the United States
can't solve this yeah right exactly you
know and I don't I don't know why it's
it's insane to me that people are so
fervent about it CU it's like I got an
idea let's uh secure borders bring
manufacturing back to this country get
rid of these garbage International
agreements like TPP and make America
great again and then when people are
like you're about the conflict happening
and uh no I didn't because I'm concerned
about our borders which are currently
porous and have millions of people this
is an example of one of Jesus's Parables
when he said take the plank out of your
own eye before you try and take the
speck of dust out of your brother's eye
or your friend or whatever like clean
yourself up nice one dude you got to
clean your room thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net